hello beloved drones and welcome to the
seven million Habits of Highly Effective
Hampton DeVille employee habit number
eight thirty five dress for the job you
want not the job you have find the
person whose job you want and dressed
exactly like them I got my job by
dressing by Kate for two weeks and I
pretended to be a man but don't just
trust like them you should act like them
to walk like them move your arms around
like that follow them around it's a tape
recorder to record their voice in
meetings or on the phone even it don't
follow them home steal their credit card
information write their car kiss their
children goodnight sleep put their wife
and their husband that's right
they're polyamorous why did you assume
they were let go of whatever
preconceived notions you have about what
a relationship is or can be it is the
21st century god damn it and before you
know it you'll have their job
[Music]
you